è tutto nero inchiostro
ci proveremo delle mode nel gioco di
playtime fendi sostituirà a
raggiungere i temi non mi piace
proveremo altre mode con altri
personaggi
e avete il tuo intitola novità
l'annuncio in forza al team e non avete
visto altro l'avete visto ora partirà il
trailer
[Musica]
un mistero da svelare
4 misteriose creature da scoprire
una avventura che vi lascerà col fiato
sospeso
storie paurose a scuola di misteri e ora
disponibile per il pre ordine su amazon
[Musica]
è
ora disponibile per il preordine il mio
libro storie paurose a scuola di misteri
la storia di quattro ragazzi alle prese
con un mistero arriva una supplente
misteriosa che gli assegna il compito di
fare delle ricerche su alcune creature
ma non voglia spoilerarvi altro andate
subito preordinarlo perché per il privè
dimmi che preordinano e il libro
ricevere che anche una cartolina
autografata da me è evitare quindi
cliccate poi a linkedin descrizione su
amazon e preordinate il libro è ora
pronti mettete a prenderli bob corn e
iniziamo con il primo vardè così qua un
po pv playtime vediamo quando spunterà
fuori ben di o se c'è già qualcosa di
diverso
innanzitutto prendiamo la cassetta come
sempre verde e rosa giallo e rosso
quella mio allora che dovremo mettere
poi nella porta per te allora verde rosa
rosa giallo e rosso porta aperta e
assedio evocando terrà fuori ben di
allora ecco qui le mani creta il gran al
pax tappeti che importanti dopo aver
messo la cassetta possiamo guardare il
video istruzione prendere il gran pack
che ci servirà poi per premere i vari
pulsanti in adv a chi è l'altro grand
parc
preso guarda
adesso
invece di avere due mani una rossa e una
blu c'è solo una mano blu con un'accetta
aspetto perché ben di a un accetta
l'accordo se vendi a questa è un'acqua
forse iniziare ad essere estranee le
cose vediamo dove troveremo ben
investiti a chi vuole in realtà il camp
bac
bac gran gran pack è solo blu non è blu
e rosso perché poi la mano nostra
vediamo
[Musica]
quindi vendi ha sostituito agli occhi ma
soprattutto ben dc in seguirà lo stesso
come anche i wacky però noto una cosa
importantissima e cioè ben di non ha la
chiave aspetto forse a chi va chi aveva
gioco arriva dopo ho imparato aprire la
porta prima speriamo allora che compaia
la chiave poi vediamo se c'è
qualcos'altro di
bari sono tutti ben di qualche stanno
provando a uscire dalla scatola vedi il
ben di papa prendiamo una scatola di
vending trasciniamo la scatola di ben di
guarda anche qua c'è ben di che stanno
cento dall avvocato io ho tirato un
cazzotto
però posso prenderlo sì forse sì
tirati veniva
spostato aiuto si arrabbierà
che succede e allora io non lascerei in
palio ma che ti ritrovi con una scatola
in testa poi dopo l'ora di fatto che si
arrabbierà intera di cives con forza
lasciamo stare
è scomparso anche d'acqua davvero guarda
non c'è più stanno scomparendo tutti che
strano non c'è più nel quale può vediamo
le altre scatole se c'è tu lo vedi no è
scappato questa è una macchia nera come
la matia di adattare il nostro ma c'è
ancora vedi contro certo adesso è
scappato sesso e sembra che lo sto
prendendo a schiaffi sta uscendo fuori
piano piano tirato fuori la mano già
allora sono vivi anche questi io non ci
giocherei se disastro dai proviamo a
farlo cadere
[Risate]
giù da dietro aiuto
come tutti mi le chiese da dietro da
dietro alla scatola
wow che carino per ora avrà così carino
di gioco
volta non è rimasta incollata alla casa
la si schiaccerà sotto una pressa
ei 10 da lei
ha
lanciato in ohio il fatto volare dove è
ancora qua però vedi non è scappato
secondo me tra un po sparisce sei mesi
si mettono d'accordo tutti quanti ben 10
chiudono da qualche parte penso che dopo
si arrabbierà molto
diversa è peggio calco blemi scorsa
verità
è che ho già detto che se questo video
raggiunge i 6 milioni piace non mi
ricordo prima ho detto 6000 7000 il
prossimo mode sarà
gremito niente lasciami in pace questo
belli anche se vorrei prenderlo e
portarlo con me perché troppo carino
francese è molto pericoloso ma sembra
super carino qui sorride a reti 6 penso
carino secondo me fa più paura beni o
aghi waki scrivetelo nei commenti
a me fa più paura di walkie la verità è
che anche a me perché qua sempre sotto
caino e di no come in realtà anche le
piante as pauroso non fatevi ingannare
dal suo sorriso va bene abbiamo
tormentato ben di avanza ora procediamo
malaman guai attiviamo l'elettricità
sono apparse le chiavi ho sentito rumore
di chiavi stiamo
zitti dove non c è cole vedi no ero
coperto non avevo
le chiavi ben di ancora qua non si è
mosso per ora anche il pupazzo e ancora
qua
gran pac
ok
vediamo se ora vuol dire vi ricordate
qua compariva all'improvviso la mano di
aghi waki vediamo se raccontano di beni
per acqua o forse ti amo c'era più
avanti e da voi aiuto
vicoli ciechi si missy mi sembra tutto
regolare quindi che si visti ora non è
più attiva di tubi vantato ma e
basilicata
forse non sarà molto contenta ok ora tv
amon elettricità con l'elettricità
sapete cosa succede davvero ok diamo per
attivare l'elettricità proviamo poi
bisogna trarne al palo e il palo e qui
veli per lunga parte nata andiamo ora a
vedere è scappato
è scappato perché ultima con
l'elettricità ben di ha preso vita
guarda però il pupazzo è ancora lì per
terra ciao ciao laura fraser nato
provando non ho capito perché val di
vara punto qui va di là
c'è qualcosa di strano in queste bambine
soldato dritto al punto lui che va
chiuso dall'altra parte lui stesse come
via mi avesse tipo un qualcosa che devi
alla mano perché avete qui va dritto
però quando mi avvicino a lui aiuta
paura che regge ritroviamo ben di noi
carni ad ama chiamarle ok come dobbiamo
fare adesso vedeva lavoro la rosa che
vediamo se si vede che cos'è volendo
vedere piano
era chi vuoti o 20 secondo me era ben di
perché era pero
tu
vedi tutti teniamo
il fumo
non mi ricordo dove era però che
dobbiamo mettere questi quasi no no io
non prendere tutti i colori così potremo
prendere l'altra mano riflette anche
l'altra mano a questa arma strana tipo
accetta con la cavalla creatura che
settembre ecco quello che emerge è vero
che ha già il giallo
forse perde forza il giallo quindi ce ne
manca ancora uno e dobbiamo come il calo
è stato facilissimo questa volta
perché non riesco a prenderlo preso via
attiviamo la fabbrica del sud
compreso preso calcio la scatola meno
male non c'era vasi destra allora
mettiamo subito la cassetta così intanto
va e se si può sbloccare voi per il
prossimo passaggio non vedo l'ora di
vedere come sarà un dandy gigante che di
vita ai due tutti eccoci qua allora
verde giallo e rosso
per una carica
sta prendendo l'altra mano
vediamo come allora va bene per una mano
e l'ha
presa anche dai non accetta adesso
possiamo apprezzare ritiro eventi o
affettare qualcosa non lo so magari lo
so un'anguria l'aspettiamo
c'entra c'entra sempre quanto c'è di che
si tratta di mangiare senza c'entra
sempre ok apriamo la porta pronti ad
entrare non ha mica vi ricordate in
questo forte superveloce si distrugge
tutta tipo di casco per avere addosso
non è il corso è già quasi che fanno
acqua forse no vediamo via sembra cibo
una montagna russa
dove dobbiamo andare
forse abbiamo sbagliato che sia attivato
necessità cosa si farà diamo per
attivare la fabbrica materiale mai
abbiamo ottenere la faccia molto tutto
di terminare età pensavo che stesse
accadendo
amiamo dio vediamo ora dovrebbero
vedersi i vari giocattoli che ci cascano
addosso vediamo ecco
stiamo per andare verso ben di gigante
ecco dove siamo finiti aiuto per un
momento si è messo fuori dalla public
veramente non me ne sono accorto ora
dobbiamo tirare anche la crescita sopra
arriverà ben gigante
come si faceva è quella cosa inghilterra
non l'avevo mai vista vecchio che strano
ai due un capo dell'alta
dell'elettricità ci siamo quasi
pronti praticati vai
ok abbiamo attivato il resto della
fabbrica ora dobbiamo creare il
giocattolo e poi
non lo so se mourinho non mi sono fatta
rionale
allora dobbiamo premere il bottone se
non ricordo male qui estrattiva la
fabbrica ora vado perché l'inflazione
faticato qualcosa forse bisognava
attivare le leve prima
abbiamo sbagliato quando buffon dice
forse non abbiamo attivato se nelle
lettere d amore controllare perché
sembra che nessuna di queste leve stia
funzionando
mi sa che non abbiamo attivato bene
l'elettricità manca una cassetta qui
sono stati di metterlo a cassetta il
videoregistratore
e dov'era la cassetta eccola si ok la
mostra voterà cassetto e poi dovrebbe
azionarsi si spera
ok ok ok che cosa sta succedendo vedo
delle cose rosse delle fiamme rosse che
escono non lo so briga si attiva alle
leve
giocattolo ha spiegato ci sono delle
cose rosse che escono dalle dita per
tutto
forse è ben di che sta già facendo
qualcosa
e ti ricordi che anche ben di però ci
avevo la pressa e tutto quanto vi sembra
proprio perfetto è vero dove sei davvero
arrivare ora dobbiamo solo prendere il
giocattolo e aprile la porta siete
pronti a far uscire il giocattolo da
liszt e comprenderlo premi lo prendono
presto mai diverso giocattolo
dove sono mancano la prima volta che
abbiamo giocato da chivu chi era tipo di
gioco
che paura che così
è tutto nero inchiostro
è un carattere più paurosa di beni
e così ora provo io vediamo se ben di ci
insegue anche aspetta dove dovrete
vedere qui mai chiuse si apre quando lui
arriva a 39 radio mar se no non credo
che ce la farò ma proviamo con shift 2
più veloce
ma io non posso fare per portare devi
stare della squadra vice al bar sala
brighi ok niente
va
benissimo
vediamo se ben di no non c'è non ci
posso andare tranquilla tranquilla
proprio
ci sono dei rumori strani vero mondo non
c'è nessuno
perché hanno scopi
ok ora prova a vitale a scappare da
belli
che brutti
mamma mia
stiamo andando bene secondo giusti
ricordati che puoi di originare
non mi
aiuta
e aspetta un momento non abbiamo provato
a tirare queste sorta di accette in
faccia vedi fra nuove cose lì possiamo
provare così vediamo se funziona per di
questo
ei perché non ce l'hai rosso
ehi perché non gli fanno niente rochette
e spettacoli prendersi
l'applauso preordina testoni paura che a
scuola di mister e uomo più preso la
cartolina autografata all'icann
descrizione cliccate ora vi lasciamo qui
c'è una salita di cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cade su quella che
preferite buona visione ciao